so here's what we're going to do this is
going to be our example and then i'm
going to set you to work the exercise
already there in canvas
we've just looked at how similar the dot
product in 3d
is to the dot product in 2d if you use
this formula it's identical
right but there are things you can do
in three dimensions you can't do in two
dimensions read this question with me
11.
find a vector that's perpendicular to
both
uh there's my screen recording uh i
minus j
plus 2k and
2i plus j minus 3k there's the question
seems simple enough right someone tell
me why this has to be
a 3d question not just because it's isjs
case why is there no
equivalent question in 2d any takers
read the wedding the question think
about this what are you thinking wren
um
vectors that are not parallel
very good let me just say that you can
see if i got you right brent in two
dimensions
if you have any two arbitrary vectors
that aren't parallel because obviously
they are parallel what's the point like
something perpendicular
to one will be perpendicular to the
other if you have two non-parallel
vectors
right then if someone says to find
something perpendicular to both of them
you can't do it right you can put be
perpendicular to one of them let's put
it over here
that's perpendicular to one but not the
other right here's another one it's
perpendicular to this one but clearly
not to the other one in 2d you're either
perpendicular to this one or you're
perpendicular to that one
but in 3d you can be perpendicular
to both how can we use the dot product
how does the dot product help us
with this think back right to the
starter lesson to be orthogonal and
perpendicular we would say
yeah dot product of zero right so what
we want to do is set up some
arbitrary vector so if we've got uh what
are the numbers here again
i got one negative one two one negative
one two what's the other one
two one three two one and there you go
thank you very much so here's our two
vectors that we're starting with
there's some other vector x y
z right and if we compute dot product
for these it should be zero
if we compute dopamine for these it
should also
be zero now i want you to start set that
up
it's not entirely straightforward
because once you do those two
some questions still remain i wanna see
if you can push through them
together and by yourselves i'll show you
the answer shortly but
can you start by at least working out
those two dot products and then thinking
about what will you do
with those dot products to work out our
third vector
give it a go and give you a few minutes
to have a play on your own
so whoopsie daisy my xz plane
um what have we got here i haven't
helped you out very much
but hopefully you got these two
equations where do these two equations
come from
not a rhetorical question yeah these are
two dot products right
and i'm saying they're both equal to
zero you can see in fact in my working
right
we've said this a lot we said it a heck
of a lot in
proof but it's always true right um
clarity over brevity a lot of you just
went straight to these two equations i
would really like you
to tell me where those equations came
from so you can see my little preamble
up the top there okay
now i then have these two equations and
then everything comes to a screeching
halt
right because you're like wait a second
i've got two unknowns
sorry i've got three unknowns and only
two equations
to solve them with right which is
usually kind of a problem
now i'm going to try and tease out for
you why it isn't a problem in fact it
has to be this way
that you've only got two equations to
try and solve for three unknowns
by bringing you back to the wording of
the question just come and have a look
back with me i had this brief
conversation with some of you but not
most of you
the question doesn't say find the vector
that's perpendicular to to these two
other ones
it doesn't say find the vector because
the vector would imply that there is
only
one right but in fact there isn't just
one vector that's perpendicular both
those there is
there are infinitely many in fact we can
find
all of them in a way okay so therefore
that's why we don't get
a third equation because that would
uniquely define there's a single x a
single y
single z there isn't a single x y and z
right that's why we have this kind of
unexpected freedom in solving the
question so here's what we have to do
we actually need to select a value that
will help us
to you know eliminate you know the three
unknowns
so this is going to sound really weird
but i'm just going to say
let x equal 1. i'm just going to
consider a convenient value
right now you might think x equals 1 i
mean it's not complicated but why not
choose something
even simpler like x equals 0.
like x equals 0 will make things even
easier to solve wouldn't it
i'm going to let you think for the next
three or four minutes in the background
while i go and see the implications of
this
why i haven't chosen and why in fact
real bad idea to choose
let x equal zero we'll return back to
that after you've had some thinking time
let's see what happens when i try this
value
i'm going to get 1 minus y plus 2z
equals 0 and
2 plus y minus 3z also equals 0.
is that all right i'm going to call this
1a so i remember where it came from and
i'm going to call this 2a
so i remember where it came from now
what are you going to do with them
add them together that's that seems like
a fairly reasonable thing to do
when you add them your y's cancel right
so when i do 1a
plus two a i'm gonna get the y's are
gone
i'm gonna get three what else on the
left hand side normal wise
minus z that equals zero so i clearly
get a value for z
and then hopefully it doesn't take you
too long to substitute back in you get a
value for y
namely who's already got it
it's seven right if you go ahead and you
put z equals three into either of these
you should get dot dot y equals
7. so what does this tell us this tells
us that
one of the vectors that's perpendicular
to
these two should be the vector
let's have a look make sure you get your
order right because we didn't
calculate their order in the order that
they come it's not one
three seven it's one seven
three is that all right yeah now if you
didn't uh take the prompt already i'd
love you to open up your device and pull
open 3d
geodrive just google it if you can't
remember oh i need to unfreeze this
you've got you've got your 3d coordinate
space set up
i didn't really show you this in detail
before but you can input like 3d jobs
built for this right you can input
vectors very easily into 3d geometry
if you follow these instructions fairly
closely you've got a proper keyboard
there so
mine sort of defaults there but if you
use lowercase and you say something like
say for example you
and then you say equals if i go back to
my correct keyboard here
u equals if you define
your coordinates here like say one
negative one and two and you just put
them in between brackets like you
normally would with coordinates
once you put those in comma two
um you can see it just immediately gives
you a vector it's a bit hard to see
because it's coming out into the first
octant well actually it's not the first
octane i'll take it back it's the second
i guess i'm actually not sure
what order it is as you go around but
there it is there's
the vector that we wanted and once you
click away you can see it go
it reverts into column form just to show
you it knows it's a vector
so there's u uh let's go ahead and put
the next one in i guess
i'm gonna call it v if by the way you
put a capital it'll give you a
coordinate rather than a vector so
that's why
it's important to be in lower case what
did we say it was 2
comma 1 comma negative 3.
all right by the way if you've set it to
default
you can see this line is or this vector
rather is dotted and that's because it's
hiding
underneath our xz plane can you see that
so anything that's hidden behind a plane
will go
will go dotted like that so there it is
so here are two original vectors
okay now we're going to put in the
vector that we found what were um
what were its components again 173.
so i'm going to call it w uh
because i have the imagination of a nat
so we're going to call it 1 comma 7
comma 3 and then suddenly
it appears but you're like um in 2d it's
not immediately clear that that is
correct so you need to and this is why
i'm asking you to
have a play with it you need to spin it
around right so let's have a look at say
the
the new vector and um the first vector
which i've called you right
if you get it at the right orientation
i'm going to spin it around this way
if you look at it with the right plane
as your perspective
you're like oh bam there's the right
angle that i was hoping for can you see
that
uh sort of coming down and then
launching off so there's one
seven three being perpendicular how am i
perpendicular to the other one because
we established in two dimensions you
can't be perpendicular to vectors
well you just need to find the
appropriate angle
there it is roughly okay that gives this
new plane this second
plane the right perspective and you now
can see the right angle between the
second vector
and our vector make sense so that's how
we know our answer is right
why did i say uh we shouldn't start
with x equals zero why is that a bad
idea
what happens if you let x equal zero we
run into this problem right you're like
oh
no problems like i get really simple
equations i get uh
minus y plus 2 z equals 0
here and then i get y minus 3 z
equals 0 and i can try to solve this
just like i did before
add these two equations to eliminate the
y's and then you're like oh
minus z equals zero so z zero if z zero
then
y is also zero uh-oh or i shouldn't have
done that way
this is the answer i've got now i want
you to call your mind back
think think think think back to
extension one right this vector has a
name what's it called
the zero vector because full of zeros
right do you remember us thinking about
the fact that the zero vector
despite the fact doesn't go anywhere
right it actually has a relationship to
every other vector out there
right we said it was parallel
to every other vector like these guys
right but weirdly it's very strange
right
if it's parallel to every other vector
that also means it's
perpendicular to every other
vector does that make sense the dot
product just shows you right we know
going back to the 2d dot product if you
compare any vector and the zero vector
you'll get a dot product of zero that
means perpendicular question mark right
so this is not a helpful answer we would
call this mathematicians would call this
the trivial case
true but completely unhelpful right so
that's why starting at some other value
will help
what happens if you uh put in something
bigger like say
x equals two if you go ahead and you
crunch them i can tell you right now
you're going to get 2
14 6. you're going to get a different
scalar multiple of this guy right
if you put in x equals negative 1 it's
going to be the same vector but facing
in the
opposite direction you'll get negative 1
negative 7 negative 3 still
perpendicular because they're on the
same
line that stretches out forever does
that make sense